what are your thoughts on balance
transfer credit cards I have three
credit card debts I'm paying off in baby
step two and the interest rates are
really high would it be wise to transfer
it to a zero percent interest rate card
while I am paying them off no I'm not a
fan of these balance transfer cards and
one of many reasons is that it doesn't
solve the root problem you going into
debt another reason is the three to five
percent they charge you just to do this
which means if you transfer 10 grand
you're paying an extra 500 bucks for the
pleasure of continuing to be in debt
with a zero percent offer that will soon
run out while you're still in debt and
then we're back to square one interest
rates aren't your problem the guy in
your mirror is your problem you need to
quit spending like you're freaking in
Congress and you be living on beans and
rice rice and beans and don't talk to me
about you deserve to go out to eat you'd
be a broke person in credit card debt
you don't get to go out to eat broke
people don't do that crap